Hi, everybody.
My name is Brittany, and, like I to mention
ed, I recently moved out to Denver to be an
instructor at Turing School of Software and
Design.
I've been teaching front-end web development
for two years now, and one of the things we
emphasise with our students is they should
be using proper vocabulary, and articulating
themselves appropriately.
Our student had a tendency to have a block
of code and described it by saying things
like, "This thing called this over here, and
then that moves over here, and this things
calls this and sends information over there."
We are like I don't understand what you're
saying.
We were teaching them the proper terms to
use and the terms they should avoid as well.
In doing so, I started to realise we have
a lot of bizarre jargony words in our industry
that we use, words that I wouldn't normally
think twice about.
My students would either laugh at or ask me
questions about, and I realised I didn't know
how to explain some of them.
So that prompted me to do a little bit of
research, and look some of the terminology
we use.
I made a tiny list of words I'm going to talk
about today with all of you.
Our first example is the term "bug".
And this is one of the most classic origin
stories that we have in programming.
The term "bug" was popularised in the 1940s
by a Harvard University technical team.
They found an actual moth in one of their
machines causing it to malfunction, so, noted
computer scientist Grace Hopper removed that
moth and taped it to a bug log, if you will
with the caption "first actual case of bug
being found".
So, this was not the very first instance of
that term being used in programming.
The phrase "bugs in a computer" had been used
frequently before then.
Back in that day, computers were really big,
and they were really hot, so they often attracted
flies and moths that would cause the machines
to malfunction.
Even though this team didn't coin the term,
this incident caused the widespread popularity
of the term "bug" which led rise to the term
"debugging" as well.
Since then, a couple of people have criticised
the term "bug", because it distances the developers
from blame.
It implies that it was something other than
developer error that caused the programme
to malfunction.
So, some computer scientists have offered
up a couple of alternatives, like "defect"
and, my favourite, "blunder".
Neither of them really took off, although
I would love to see us create "blunder reports"
— I think that would be hilarious.
I think "bug" is pretty much here to stay.
That's one of the most concrete examples of
an origin story that we have for a term that
we are using in programming.
Other words are a little bit hazier, or it's
a little bit more difficult to track down
concrete origins of where they came from.
But they still have really interesting theories
behind them, and interesting metaphors that
we can pull out of them.
One of my favourite is "throw" and "catch".
When you're programming, maybe you have some
try catch blocks, and you're going to throw
an exception that is going to be caught.
The first appearance of these terms in programming
was in MacLisp which is a dialect of the Lisp
language in 1972.
They had two more error-handling primitives
which were throw and catch.
The lead developers working on this language
at the time were American, and in America,
the sport of baseball is really popular.
I know it's not very widespread elsewhere
— probably because it is incredibly boring!
— but it offers an insight to the explanation
of these terms.
In baseball, a player can commit a throwing
error.
The player might throw the ball just slightly
out of reach for their team-mates, or the
ball might take an un-Special Constable bounce,
or maybe it hits team-mate, or a base.
Any number of things could go wrong there.
But ultimately, the goal for each one of these
throws, is to catch that ball, to reduce the
amount of damage that that error is actually
going to do, right?
So we have the same concept in programming,
where we want to catch any exceptions that
are thrown, and surface those errors as soon
as possible, as provide as much information
about what went wrong so our programmes don't
fail in these catastrophic ways, Day okay?
That's an example of one of the theories that
is not completely set in stone.
A little bit more speculative, but still offers
us a metaphor on how to think about these
terms that we work with every day.
Let's talk about foobar a little bit.
Who uses foobar bath?
Me to.
I used to.
I stopped recently, and I will get into that
in a little bit.
People understand why?
Yep.
So, foobar was first used in programming by
MIT's tech model railroad club, and this club
was essentially a bunch of nerds or kid playing
with model train sets, right?
They built this complex system for automating
train sets, and these systems had a bunch
of kill switches where you would trigger one
if something catastrophic was going to happen,
a train was going to crash in another train
or other obstruction.
They had had little dashboard alongside their
system that usually showed, like, a counter
or a clock — something of that sort — but
whenever one of these kill switches was engaged,
the dashboard instead flashed the word "foo".
So thing about how "foo" was being used here
to represent and denote that something terrible
happened, okay?
This leads us into the origin of where foobar
came from.
As an instructor, I do a lot of demonstrative
coding for my students, and I was using foobar
for a biochemical, until one of my students,
who was a veteran, was explaining that foobar
was a military slang term.
That stood for "messed up beyond all recognition",
right?
So people would use this term talking about
the missions that they were on, often sometimes
the severity of the injuries that soldiers
sustained, right?
And, in the tech world, we decided to try
to soften the definition of this acronym and
like, "It doesn't stand for it, it actually
stands for fouled up beyond all repair for
our software", and we changed the spelling
a little bit, but we still maintained that
phonetic composition that we have with this
they remember, right?
So even — with this term.
Even though we try to soften the way we use
these terms or make them more gentle, those
original conceptions are still there, right?
This term can still be very triggering for
certain people.
The software engineering community has no
lack of terms with negative connotations to
them.
Think about the terms "master/slave".
We've done a decent job of trying to get that
out of our vocabulary but it won't easy.
In 2003, the city of Los Angeles, or county
of Los Angeles, had filed a request that manufacturers
stop using those terms in their products,
and the tech industry being the tech industry
was, "No, we want to keep our terms master/slave,
don't tell us what to do," and they got really
angry about it.
Los Angeles was, "Sorry, never mind, it was
just a request," and kind of backed off.
But the following year, the global language
monitor decided to name master/slave as the
most politically incorrect term of 2004.
Which was really great response to that incident,
I thought.
"Whitelist, blacklist" — I had another scenario
in class one day where one of my students
some some documentation on MDM that used a
variable called "whitelist", and they were
trying to rework some of the code in that
example but were putting things that should
be blocked into this whitelist array.
As I was trying to explain to him what it
meant, I was, "Think about the difference
between a whitelist and a blacklist".
I kind of stopped myself short realising how
negative those terms are in the modern-day
connotations that those have nowadays.
The origin of those terms, for anyone that
might not be following, they imply anything
that is white is good, and anything that is
black is bad.
There are a lot of different reasons for the
origins of those terms, and maybe perhaps,
when they came around, they weren't necessarily
racist, or they didn't hold the connotations
that they do today, but a because they hold
those connotations today, they should definitely
be removed from our vernacular as well, our
vocabulary.
I'm going on tangents here.
Let me get back to a couple of other words.
Thunks — sub routines used to inject additional
logic or calculations into other sub routines.
So I teach React and Redux at Turing, and
this is where we introduce our students to
thunks, they use them for asynchronous actions
that they are creating.
And they're what on earth is a thunk?
A lot of people thought this term originated
because of a sound.
They think clearly about a sound that would
be occurring from this, so maybe it was the
sound of data hitting the information — information
hitting the stack, or data hitting an accumulator
— that is what a lot of people reference
this term to.
But the origin is from a late night of programming
years ago where a couple of developers were
thinking really hard about how they needed
this type of argument at a certain point in
execution of their programme, and they didn't
have that value right away but they realised
that they could get that information in advance
with a — by adding a couple of extra calculations
at compile time.
In their minds, they thought, "Okay, if we
add these calculations ahead of time, now
this variable, this value, has already been
thought of, it has already been thought about,"
hence "thunk" is the past-tense version of
think, or past tense of think.
So that is what that term actually means here.
Shell: this was a fun one to research.
This is, this was a fun one to research.
It is a command line or our terminal, what
we are actually interacting with is our shell,
and we are interacting with this shell rather
than the kernel or the central core of our
operating system, right?
So nuts work the same exact way.
They have — they're a fruit, and they have
this very hard external shell that does not
allow you access to that inner seed, or that
inner kernel.
That's the metaphor there.
When I was researching this one, there were
a lot of threads where people were getting
very philosophical about things, and really
deep about what it could possibly mean.
They were like, "Oh, the shell is like a sea
shell from the ocean, and there this concept
of listeners, and you can listen to the ocean
when you put a sea shell up to your ear,"
and people were making up these convoluted
metaphors, and someone said, listen, it is
just a nut, that's all it is.
And the conversation stopped after he mentioned
that.
We have a tendency to overthinking things,
for sure, when we try to come up with metaphors
and examples of what things might mean, okay?
So that is just a handful of words that I
have picked out from a very long list.
If you're interested in learning more words,
and learning more terminology, there's a book
called the New Hackers' Dictionary, which
isn't quite new any more, it is actually pretty
dated.
I think it was around 1996 when it was being
actively updated, but there are a lot of other
terms in that dictionary are that are humorous
like woga-woga, barfulation, nasal demons.
These are considered hacker terms.
I got a good laugh as I was looking through
the glossary, reading of some these terms.
But, at the same time, alongside these more
humorous and more interesting terms in this
dictionary, there are a lot of upsetting words,
words that very clearly indicate some of the
cultural issues that we are still dealing
with today in programming.
Words like "tits on a keyboard".
"Tar and feather", "rape", these are all considered
programming terms according to that dictionary,
right?
In the beginning of that book, they say, "All
human cultures use slang in this three-fold
way: as a tool of communication, and of inclusion,
and of exclusion."
I want to take the last part of this talk
to talk a little bit about this exclusion
piece.
One of the ways in which the language that
we use in programming is the most exclusion
ry lies in how biased it is towards native
English speakers, how much it favours native
English speakers.
I had a student recently who was a perfectly
talented developer.
She was very able to write all of the code
and build all of the application s, but where
she felt she was falling behind as a native
Spanish speaker was that gasping that articulation
piece, so, talking about the code, and listening
to others speak about it.
The terms and metaphors that we use that might
make perfect accepts to you might be absolutely
meaningless to someone else.
There is a discussion on a GitHub thread recently
where a developer was discussing how the terms
"property" and "attribute" translate to the
exact same word in Chinese.
Even though they mean slightly different things
when we talk about them in English.
So, their solution to overcome this is to
prefix that word with either DOM, when they
were talking about a DOM property, or HTML,
when they were talking about an HTML attribute.
That would help them avoid any confusion they
might have ran into.
This was eye-opening to me, and I wanted to
hear more stories what else was out there,
and how are people struggling within this
industry dominated by English?
So I interviewed a couple of developers, and
I surveyed about 30 which is still a small
sample set.
But I surveyed non-English speakers about
their experiences being engineers, developers,
tech-based biased towards English speakers.
Before the themes came up was that there was
a longer learning curve for these developers,
so not only were they trying to learn the
programming language, at the same time, they
were trying to learn the written and spoken
language that explained it in the first place.
Sometimes, there were no translations for
certain terms that we use in programming;
sometimes, there would be a translation, but
maybe it would cause even more confusion if
that translation was not a perfect one-to-one
correlation with the original term.
A developer at the New York Times and native
Polish speaker said, "I have no idea what
Polish people call a variable in Polish.
Not knowing the words in my native language
definitely adds some sense of artificiality
to the programming terms."
So it is very difficult to derive meaning
from terms that seem like they're mid-up,
terms that you have not recognised in your
native language, right?
Another theme I noticed was that people had
difficulty getting help also recognising when
they actually needed help, so, some people
mentioned that it was challenging to find
the right search terms to use when tackling
a bug that they were encountering.
I know I still have problems with that as
a native English speaker, so there's an added
layer of complexity there for some people.
A loft people mentioned — a lot of people
mentioned reading issue threads and pull requests
wasn't worth it because there was too much
slang involved in those threads that convoluted
the discussion, and made it really difficult
for them to follow.
The developer I was talking about, Ana, was
also mentioning that, when she would read
documentation, she would have to double-check
with her co-workers?
Do I is not not understand this because it
is poorly written or do I not understand this
because of a gap in my English proficiency?
So this was another check that people had
to do for themselves in order to understand
whether or not it was them, or something that
was prewritten poorly.
We all know how much documentation is written
poorly out there, and how many bad resources
there are out there, so I can't imagine having
that additional challenge.
By far one of the biggest barriers for people
seems to be community involvement, and the
judgment that came along with that, so, I
think everyone here can agree that community
involvement is so essential for your growth,
and your learning, and enjoyment, and success
in the industry, right?
In your career.
It is such a vital part of being involved
in this industry that it is a shame that people
start to feel less out of it.
Some people mentioned that they would have
a hard time following a technical conversation,
not because they weren't skilled enough, or
because they didn't have the technical knowledge,
but simply because it would be a large group
of people talking very fast about a particular
topic, and that made it challenging for them
to follow along which made it look as if they
didn't know what people were talking about.
My friend Bella mentioned that she produces
materials in English, like screencasts, articles,
and talks, and sometimes, people will question
her materials, or her technical prowess, her
skill set because of a spelling or grammar
mistake or an accent.
Very simple things.
There's this added layer of having to prove
yourself now if you have this barrier that
most of us are un familiar with.
So a lot of people did say some positive things
about their community involvement but overall,
the tone felt kind of lonely, and I think
this is something we should definitely be
working on as an industry.
And based on some of the responses that I
was getting, there were definitely some things
that stood out to me that we could start doing,
and things that people mentioned, so, one
of those was when you're creating resources,
try to use more illustrations and charts,
and graphs.
Those are more universal, and often help clarify
things where written text falls short.
Lynn Clark got a really great shout out from
one of the respondents for all the work she's
been doing there.
If we could make an effort to do something
like that, that would be super helpful.
Limiting the slang in issues we use in PR
threads.
If we can aim for words that might be translated
more easily in other languages.
It might feel sill y and robot ic at first
but it will help break town barriers for developers
that would be super helpful.
Lastly, we need to be working with native
speakers of other languages to create these
resources, to create better resources, more
universal resources.
I'm not exactly sure just what this looks
like yet, but I'm hoping to collect more data
and more experiences, so that we can figure
that out.
I'm sure a lot of people here have dealt with
some of these issues.
They've experienced these things.
I would love to hear from all of you if you
have.
I plan on keeping my survey open indefinitely
so that people can continue to respond to
it, so I will tweet that out in a little bit.
But any experiences that you have, anything
that you think we can be doing to alleviate
some of these difficulties that we're causing
for other developers, I would love to talk
with you more about that, okay?
Feel free to find me during the breaks, or
after all the talks.
If you have any insight or experiences you
want to share, or maybe some other terms and
origin stories that you find with interesting,
I would love to hear about them.
Hope you enjoy the rest of the conference.
Thank you.
[Applause]